hi my name is Ellie beer and I'm an
answer I live in Israel and I social
entrepreneur and I am here to answer a
question what is your favorite dog loose
moments so this was by Virginia in
Australia yeah from Melbourne Australia
she asked this question so well my
favorite moment in Davos is definitely
meaning whoever never never never meet
frequently however those real cell would
never need someone from Saudi Arabia
only why it doesn't happen every time
walking around Tel Aviv so we meeting
them here in Davos is a great
opportunity to say hello and to share
your interest between the you know Pepe
you're getting to know people who are
normally not me and you know as you see
I wear like a keeper religious chew and
growing up in Israel I never met people
from Kuwait Saudi Arabia or other
countries all around this is this is
really a capital on the world here in
Davos right now so everywhere you go you
mean employer comes from countries when
you hear about ollie on CNN or another
you know networks and getting to know
the people and you see that there isn't
a big difference between ossicles we all
have the same problems we all have
children that we want to make sure
they're safe and we all have families
that we have to make sure we provide
enough for them so I sure that what I do
in Israel is united at Ella those really
which is a non-profit corresponding
organization throughout Israel which
reaches every emergency with into a
necklace an average and explain to them
how this can happen telling the American
happy in their countries were there
shocked to see that this the great idea
which is so obvious where you can have
first responders during their daily
thing and working wherever they work and
volunteering anytime
when emergency happens and jumping out
of bed three o'clock in the morning to
save their neighborhood when he's having
a heart attack by our people and a
little child is choking so this is what
id like and having everyone happy so I
want to spread United outside of Israel
all over the world it should be United
some of Yemen you know to tell of his
ranch the Arizona any country in the
world and this is the only place and I
actually walk around crowd the crowd who
i am and share these ideas with other
people so they're proud were they are
there they are and you can share these
ideas to give themselves Davos is the
place Thank You Raja